I'm a very slow typer that's part of why
we're parents
there's a bunch of them it's making me
very emotional is there a translator is
such a thing as too many options smooth
to homeless so young people do this so
that they could hide their conversations
from their parents from spawn this
correct
you're using emojis I know I this is so
stupid I don't know how to communicate
like this
okay I'm ten minute okay so rear sent me
something with just two emojis a dog Oh
doggone lose lizard there's an Erica
haha take the same one did you pick up
the mail yeah hey then we'll go with
mine okay bigger or lanius oh god I'm in
trouble
you're always coming home from running
Oh your smile like it's like this you're
still running uh fist no no man you
wrote it out long I can't see the emoji
is so small do you know how small these
are on here okay now you are the
opposite of me where you have one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirty forty fifty sixteen
emojis I'm an overachiever is it a
letter uh-huh so mail uh-huh that was
supposed to be not a cars post via
pickup oh I got I got I got it yeah you
lady going to the store in your minivan
buy me all these foods that's right are
you going to the store it's a car I
couldn't find it
a pickup well how am I supposed to I put
the eggplant in there Joey sassy I only
have four characters - you're what
twelve planet emoji hey thanks for penis
does it really oh my gosh kids today are
so dirty
it was hard I'm better at it than I
thought that's my takeaway I don't know
I just don't get it I mean it makes
sense on Instagram when you're like
trying to express an emotion
with emoji but why would you like try to
communicate I don't think this is for me
it's not for me either
maybe that's what emoji is really about
is helping us get closer to emotional
communication your brain implants